BRENDON HARRINGTON:
Hey, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
Thanks for joining us today.
I'm Brendan from the
transportation team.
It's my very big
privilege and honor
to introduce Stana Katic today.
She's here from LA.
You know her as the
TV and film actress.
One of her big hits, of course,
is the TV show "Castle."
Beyond that, though,
she's a strong advocate
for the environment
and for transportation.
Having lived
throughout the world,
she's often observed
transportation issues
in many different places.
She's very passionate about
not accepting this car centric
fate, and so she's
dedicated her time
to a new organization called
the Alternative Travel Project,
just a few years old now.
She's going to share a little
bit more about her experiences,
so join me in welcoming her.
[APPLAUSE]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[PIANO MUSIC]
-In the early 1900s,
Henry Ford set out
to make an automobile
anyone could afford.
The Model T became so affordable
that a worker could buy it
in only four months' pay.
By the 1920s, the market
had reached saturation.
Those who desired a car already
owned one, as 90% of all trips
were made by rail car.
Around the 1950s, things
started to change.
"The Street Car
Conspiracy" by the author
and former US and antitrust
attorney Bradford Snell
refers to the allegations
that GM and other companies
like Firestone, through
subsidiaries, purchased
and dismantled trams,
trolleys, and electric trains
in many cities across the
United States in order
to eliminate the car industry's
number one competitor.
Others argue that the fall
of public transportation
was due to the culmination
of other factors,
such as the Depression,
labor unrest, market forces,
urban sprawl, and other causes
favoring private vehicle
ownership.
One author was quoted as
saying, clearly, GM waged
a war on electric traction.
It was, indeed,
an all out assault
but by no means the single
reason for the failure
of rapid transit.
Also, it is just as clear
that the actions and inactions
by government
contributed significantly
to the elimination
of electric traction.
Americans had a wake up call
with the oil crisis of 1973,
and since then, alternative
forms of travel have been
on the rise, most notably
again in the 2000s with the US
involvement in the Middle East
and people's realizations that
we as a country cannot be
dependent on fossil fuels.
Then again, for
others, it was simply
just an idea one morning.
-You know, one summer day,
I just said, you know what?
It's time for me to just find
a new way to get to work.
I was just so tired
of being in a car,
and literally, within a
week, I had my bicycle.
[MUSIC RADIO CITIZEN, "THE HOP"]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
STANA KATIC: Hi.
My name is Stana Katic.
I am here to talk with
you today about ATP.
Many of you know ATP to
be adenosine triphosphate,
the energy carrying shuttle
service molecule found
in the cells of
all living things.
Not a very big deal,
but to me, it's
the acronym for one of
my favorite non-profits,
the Alternative Travel Project.
Oddly enough, it also happens to
be a nonprofit that I founded.
So what is ATP?
Well, it's a global
initiative that
encourages people to go
car free for just one day.
We ask people to
volunteer days outside
of the bubble of their cars
by finding new ways to travel.
And by new ways, I
mean the ancient art
of pedestrian travel, cycling,
public transit, and new tech.
That being said, I promise
you this presentation
isn't going to
end with me asking
you to throw away your Teslas.
Cars are great.
They're part of our modern day.
They just don't need to be
a part of our every day.
So why bother?
Why does transit--
or what does transit
have to do with your
average Joe other than being
a royal nuisance at 8 AM
and 5 PM, five days a week?
I have a huge list
of stats and stories
that say traveling alternatively
has reverberating effects
on so many parts of our lives--
our health, our environment,
and here's the one
that really motivates
people-- our pocketbooks.
But we have to
start somewhere, so
why don't we just start
by looking at our future?
Let's see where we
are going globally.
At the current pace
of urbanization,
the world's cities will
add 65 million inhabitants
every year-- every single
year-- for the next 10 years.
So if we break that
down, and let's
say we just look at India-- we
look at the cities of India--
they're going to have to
add as much floor space
as exists in all of Chicago.
China is going to have to
add twice that every year.
This means that traffic is
not going to get better.
It's going to get
more complicated.
I lived in Los Angeles.
Traffic already sucks.
People joke in LA about
how dating someone
on the other side of town
can be a deal breaker,
because who wants
to do long distance?
Can you guys imagine what a
population surge in that city
is going to look like?
I just got married.
I'm good.
The love of my life
lives in my zip code.
But I'm worried about my
single sisters out there.
There is a study that came
out this past February, March.
Scientists at California's
Office of Environmental Health
Hazard Assessment,
the Cancer Prevention
Institute of
California, UC Davis,
and other prestigious
science centers
linked chronic exposure
to ultra fine particles
in vehicle exhaust to
deaths from heart disease.
So ultra fine particles,
according to the study,
are a key contributor
to health problems
amongst people
living near traffic.
The study ran from 2001 to 2007.
It took a look at
100,000 middle-aged women
across California.
These women were teachers
and administrators, so people
that we need and that
we want to stick around.
So let's think about it again.
What happens when we have a
population surge in our cities?
Traffic isn't just
a health hazard.
There's a financial
cost to getting people
around a city inefficiently.
According to recent
research, congestions cost,
partly from wasting time and
the patience of commuters,
equals anywhere from 1.5% to
4% of gross domestic product.
So getting people from
one part of the city
to another efficiently and
stress free has monetary value.
So as our cities' populations
grow, what's the plan?
Where are we going?
Leaving the roadways as they
are has an economic cost,
but data also suggests
that building more roadways
isn't the answer, as well,
because that has human health
costs.
This is where we come in.
The city of Los Angeles is
one of the media capitals
of the world, as is
the city of Google.
We export lifestyle
through our stories,
through film, television,
internet content, et cetera.
And at ATP, we believe that
places like Google and Los
Angeles or
Hollywood-- we believe
we're unique on the global
stage because we have
an unparalleled
potential to effect
the vision of what an ideal
lifestyle would and could be.
Our media, our film
and television tales,
reach even the most remote
international villages
and yurts.
What kind of tales
and lifestyles
are we going to
be able to export
when the majority
of storytellers
are bound to driving as
a main mode of transit?
Transit is a
secondary thought when
it comes to much of
entertainment media content,
but driving storytellers lead
to driving scenes in movies.
I know.
I have to do them all the time.
Our lives affect our
inspiration and imagination,
and that has
reverberating effects.
That has global effects.
The messages that we plant
in global consciousness
now will dictate
where we all go.
With the extraordinary
amount of creative talent
and financial power
that circulates
through this part
of the US, we can
be at the forefront of
technological breakthroughs
and municipal services
in an unprecedented way.
And if we took a quick
moment to improve something
as simple as the
way we get around,
the benefits to health,
the benefits to business
and the environment
would be astronomical.
So I figure a city
that draws some
of the most creative
people on the planet
would be a fertile ground
for problem solving
the next generation's ideas of
what metropolitan travel has
to look like.
There is a way to make it
fun, inspiring, and safe.
And at ATP, we are
trying to be a part
of disseminating that vision.
Our first year, we asked
people across the globe
to volunteer days car free, and
the response was overwhelming.
Stories came in from everywhere,
from France, Belgium, South
Africa, Argentina, Minnesota.
I mean, everywhere.
I have shared this one often.
It's a good story, so bear with
me if you've heard it before.
There was a school
in Romania that,
as a result of this
initiative, decided
to take on the challenge
and create car free Fridays.
What happened was
that people that
were connected to
the school started
meeting each other on buses,
on sidewalks, and so on.
And a little over
a year and a half
later, there were two
weddings as a direct result
of the Alternative Travel
Project initiative.
Here's a photo.
They now have children.
So ATP isn't just about
making a love connection.
The other benefits of
engaging in an ATP lifestyle
extend beyond health
and economics.
There's something
called agglomeration.
Agglomeration essentially
means a heap or cluster
of usually disparate elements.
There is monetary value
to agglomerating people
through expanded transit.
Planning scholars from
UC Berkeley and Rutgers
believe the numbers run anywhere
from $1.5 million to $1.8
billion, depending
on a city's size.
And at Google, you guys
are doing a fantastic job
of re-envisioning transit.
I know, because I read
your Bike Vision Statement,
and if anyone here hasn't
seen it, you should.
It's very, very impressive.
In Google's vision
plan, you're part
of creating new infrastructure
in which residents
of all abilities,
from ages 8 to 80,
will feel safe and comfortable
doing things like riding around
on a bicycle here.
For a company that is at
the forefront of making
the imagined manifest,
how many more moments
of eureka, how many more ideas
will you foster into reality
by building the transit
infrastructure that
allows for agglomeration?
ATP is working to inform
and empower individuals
to choose alternative
means of transit.
We see a future where, as
cities all over the world grow,
pedestrian travel, cyclists,
cars, and public transit
hold equal value for those
building infrastructure.
We are working to arm
businesses and governments
with the data necessary
to comfortably justify
building those facilities
for the betterment
of their economies and for
the health and happiness
of their citizens.
That's where we want to go.
And if we can-- or if I
can convince one of you
in this room to use your
molecular energy ATP
to do some alternative
travel ATP, and if,
therefore, a part of
a reverberating effect
that reduces a person's risk
of heart disease or results
in you saving money so you
can take your loved one out
to dinner, or spurs a chance
meeting on a bike trail that
figures out a way to
save the polar bear,
cure cancer, protect
the Galapagos,
or build that high speed
electric party train that gets
us from San Francisco to LA,
in no time, then the places
that we are going is going to
be where everyone wants to be.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]